okay
thank you good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen fellow councillors
our guests today and those of you who
are watching live on youtube and welcome
to this afternoon's meeting this is the
external overview scrutiny committee
and i'm going to start with apologies if
you've got any apologies please yes
cherie we've got apologies from
councillor king okay thank you
okay and now we're going to look at the
minutes from the last meeting
okay we'll take the page by page
so we'll start with page one at the top
page two
that's the presentation so it's page
three
page four is still the presentation
page five
let's turn a bit on page six
happy with those minutes
do i have a proposal councillor
pennington seconded by councillor
harding please
thank you
oh yeah i always forget vote and now we
all need to put all those in favor
[Music]
okay
[Music]
puppy participation though as far as i'm
aware we don't have any public
participation today
through
um and now we're moving on to the action
list which is page nine
of your
pack
uh minute number 79 councillor manly
well that could be me um i have been in
contact with joey but i haven't actually
successfully managed to order any um
relevant funding streams yet but i'm
still working on that so we can keep
that as a progress if that's all right
please cassidy
um councillor hawkins is complete
councilman newton's complete
janet contact
we need you on that forward plan
i should take a breath
okay good
just check in
and then number 80
oh about the play strategy and that's on
our forward plan for september october
november
okay everybody happy with that
okay
declarations of interest members with
interest should refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is considered
um agreement at the agenda we don't have
any part two today
um anybody have to propose
the agenda part one do we don't need to
do it
do i need to okay no no just carry on
that's fine we'll just carry on
number seven urgent matters walk forward
with the permission of the chair
some newton's way sorry could i raise
that when it comes to a point of order
or whatever um unless i've missed
something
we have two new independent members on
the committee
they were here last time yes they were
but they weren't introduced and
everything we didn't do that
so
actually they were they were here like
to my embarrassment when i left i
realized that they were here and
actually hadn't been introduced well
you've kind of read my mind councillor
newton because i was going to get us all
to introduce ourselves i'm so sorry
benefit of these they don't know sorry i
was going to get us all to introduce
ourselves with the benefit of the ladies
here today so they know who they're
talking to and whereabouts we're from
sort of as in area and our roles in what
we do
will that be all right
indeed i just wanted to allow the
independent members to
introduce themselves so we
know who everybody is
so on that note um we have julian
heather with us today
um nada and splits do you form lisa as
you've got lisa
together or is that a different project
lisa is the is the partnership
um
um so if you'd like to introduce
yourselves we'll start with our two
independent members that are here today
uh mr kenton baker
yeah
thank you chair i'm louie bark retired
magistrate and i live in westwood hope
and i have various interests in the
community
i'm phil huntington and i'm a elected
councillor for monkey and pottford
which is several small villages but it
actually starts just outside the window
here across the valley very interested
in real issues they come up from here
and i also think this committee is
really important because
as a district council we interact with
health services and
fire services and services
planning and all the rest of it to
interact bring all the good communities
together basically so it's really
committing and i think you know given
some of the suicide statistics with
orange um i should be looking forward to
your meeting today thank you very much
i'm coach harding steve harding from
heartland ward which covers from welcome
lundy clavelli moosery
uh sup [ __ ]
and uh
um uh well we also got bucks parker um
probably so yeah it's um
yeah so it is it's a pharaoh area so
where he finishes i carry on
hi i'm councillor shirley langford and
i'm much more simple i just represent
billy food south which is physics
yeah i'm councillor hawkins so i'm
getting from the west
and most of the same sugar is always a
smaller area
nowhere near as big as these guys don't
have to cover
council simon newton and i represent uh
winkley i am the
the
sole surviving single council award in
the district
[Music]
hi i'm john williams i'm the public
health and housing manager here at
church
sandra democratic services
karen hewlett and democratic services
john manly i am the counselor for the
northern laurcher hill ward
i'm the chair of this country
i'm stacey i'm head of leaders legal
government
okay
i didn't come that way today to not came
through town because it was quickly well
wouldn't say easier quicker i should've
left
i did would you just like to introduce
yourself councillor leather please to
believe councillor chris leather
representing norden
we share don't we chris
we share
yeah
so anyway so i'm julie weaves i'm one of
the managers within split sports service
we're the commissioned
um service with downtown council to
provide service to
adults and children
in devon the whole of devon for domestic
abuse
and um
we we are the lead partner for the lisa
partnership and i thought i have brought
some leaflets along unfortunately there
are a little bit of a date in the sense
of the email so um
yeah just to note that really um
devon and college
so the lisa partnership was formed um i
think 2019
to it wasn't it wasn't a funding issue
it was more of an ethical thing the four
organizations which you can see split
sending ada stock abuse for everyone and
demographic crisis just to come together
to kind of
share all the wonderful things that we
do offer because independently we
obviously offer different things um but
as a collective we do offer an awful lot
um to the community
throughout devon um for the purposes of
today we are going to focus on schools
in the ada from stop abuse from one cup
they their
about them within the presentation
so the point of the partnership
um like i said was to come together to
look at um
ending domestic and sexual violence and
abuse in devon
okay so quite quite a huge task to do
but we are all committed to doing that
um
we're we're based across seven within
local communities we've got
officers
um
and um
lots of other agencies
the different services that um between
us we offer
um if you want to find them yeah
so we'll probably focus on our own
services
so our support is family centered we do
support um
men women children um we do support
victims we do support um
perpetrators as well
on some level um but yeah so we're very
family centered um as much as we can
within the funding that we've got um we
deal with crisis primarily splits or
crisis-led ndadia there was some crisis
but they deal with the recovery side of
transactions
yeah um and then um yeah there are we've
got qualified staff they've
all got qualifications um independent
domestic violence advisor qualifications
amongst other qualifications they may
have um yeah and we obviously work in
partnership with agencies
i'm sorry jumped ahead so yes for
women men children of all ages it's the
people um who are in domestic abuse
relationships or may have come out one
um but um
the main feature for a criteria for
referrals and foreign service
um
yeah we will work we'll work with anyone
who wants to work with us they don't
have to leave they don't have to report
to the police if we don't want to um
there are obviously safeguarding
elements to that you know we have to
do certain things sometimes but um on
the whole you know we work with anyone
we're volunteering
[Music]
over the telephone one to one although
currently we've done very little of that
over the last 18 months but um
historically we would support one to one
um we've got the women's refugee
which is the ndaea run
which means that men can use them
um
women with children that have got that
are male males that are 16 and over
can't access the refuge so there are
limitations to the refuge so there are
places of safety
yeah we do
individual work group work
we can support victims in their own
right there are 14 plus
specialist
independent
domestic violence abuse
workers for that um and yeah we've got
perfect programs or as we like to call
it behave change programs
okay and we also do recovery workshops
changing it's quite widely
quite widely known in the endeavor and
quite widely i would say um recognizing
something that's a very positive thing
for part of the covering and there are
some opportunities to access counselling
through the council service
so when that said no wrong door so part
of the the point of the lease our
partnership was so that if somebody
because there are lots of different
things lots of different of the
organizations they could ring the splits
number the o345 number and they're not
going to get sorry you've come through
to the wrong people and put the phone
down they will be um the referral will
be taken they will be
guided and explained to we we will refer
them on to say nda for instance or
demonstrate crisis um
so we didn't want people to have to try
and navigate our services which are
obviously a bit dispersed um we wanted
people to be able to think about we just
bring one number and we will get
eventually placed in the right place
so for splits we deal with high and
medium risk
service users so that means the risk is
likely to be current or recent
um
we obviously will look at a family
approach so we will include the children
in our in our
support plans
um we attend
which is i don't have the name but it's
a monthly meeting that's held in
um northern devon um to look at very
high risk cases we attend now on a
monthly basis
um we risk assess all of the people that
referring to us and we need to look at
their needs as well and what kind of
things they need
um
we regularly work with
other agencies
a huge part being
working with us is that we do want to
[Music]
okay
we then move on to some of the services
that will dominates domestic abuse
provides
and i'm going to go off kilter a little
bit and just sort of explain how come we
are where we are at the moment
um splits get funding then commission
service but for north dakota against
domestic abuse we are a charity and we
also get our funding from lots of
different streams we are constantly
fighting to be able to keep our services
going um we have different funders we've
had big lottery in the past we've had
children in need
as well as charitable fundraising things
so
a lot of our service we've had to evolve
you know for where the need is
you know survive
so
the current situation is we do provide
core infers
now
it does is independent domestic violence
advisors so if you talk about it that's
what it is
again back many years ago it used to be
support through criminal courts speak i
used to be a corporate um but as times
going on we now provide support to
family courts because we identified
there was a massive need there for
people especially those people who
weren't able to access legal aid for
example and we're representing
themselves
so we support those
who for example are going from normal
station order protective orders or
actually go through child contact issues
again we have got three port edwards for
the whole of devon excluding plymouth
until bay so there is a massive need a
massive gap and unfortunately we can
only work with those
who
like say are our most need or yeah we
need that service
so it can be very difficult because in
our ethos we want to support people we
want to support everyone we can but we
have capacity issues
so
that's what the court leaders do and
like i say they're working against
they're working in very difficult
systems as well
family court like any other has been
affected by covid um so again thoughts
um courts that are now online um you've
got people who are disadvantaged through
technology for example so struggle to
actually be able to access court
hearings for example so that's just some
of the many issues that they are
up against
hell now this to me has been a really
interesting development over the years
for men for several years through
charitable london we actually placed a
nearby hospital again working
predominantly in maternity and in a e
again that through showing
good outcomes um and being able to
evidence the good work that's done i'm
really pleased to say that now um we get
funding through more than devon
healthcare trusts and equally in exeter
um they've got funding through
the nhs as well for that role so again
it seems where there's gaps what we can
do then evidencing the impact of our
work to get that more sustainable
funding
again with that we've also
got an iris project which is providing
training and advocacy and gp surgeries
and again we're ourselves at
northwestern we recognised that there
was mental health was a significant need
that people had
so again we've had funding to
work with mental health with
people with mental health issues and
we've got complex mental health issues
so for example you know making sure they
are being able to access the correct
pathways for them within the mental
health systems um to have that advocacy
someone there to be able to work with
other professionals to
say this person needs whatever support
it is
um also obviously working on trauma
informed way
now just sticking with mental health for
a second
obviously
covered
i would say actually a significant
portion of our clients do have some form
of mental health um issues whether it be
low level anxiety depression all the way
up to ptsd
um i think that's fair to say isn't it
yeah
um
so like i say mental health is a massive
component of an issue people we work
with and especially with kovid obviously
that's exacerbating things with the
isolation that people have had not being
able to access support from other
services as well um with
a lot of services reducing
what they can provide
um
again for those people who are suffering
from mental health again this is often
used by perpetrators against them you're
mad um you know no one will believe you
um again there's a stigma of having
mental health anyway
and i would say as practitioners it is
so difficult because obviously mental
health can be impacted by the situation
that that person's in so quite often
mental health services will say you need
to sort out the domestic abuse however
these people
you know a lot of our clients do have
can or do have mental health issues so
we are trying to support them
and quite often we will have people
refer to us for counseling for example
and it
can be very frustrating you know you're
sort of thinking that why can't mental
health support you know provide some of
these services
um i don't know if there's something
else you wouldn't say on the mental
health side
um
i think
for splits what we've noticed with our
clients is that we are holding clients a
lot much longer than we would normally
so um
you know we
maybe endeavor to reduce the risk and
improve their safety but because of
their mental health
unable
[Music]
health trained yes
we've done bits and pieces but that's
not our speciality so it is
quite challenging at times um to try to
manage that um clearly we have to you
know
manage it anyway like i said the
majority of our whites will have anxiety
um
issues related to their situation um but
yeah so that's probably one of the
biggest features over covered for us is
um the length of the duration of time we
have to support them a lot longer
because they're not needed to access the
specialist support
thank you
we also find finding new voice this is
another service that we provide again
after people have um
come out with domestic abuse
relationships again we look at trying to
get people the appropriate support in
terms of aiding their recovery so that's
where a finding voice comes in
working one-on-one with individuals
again
issues such as child contact that can
take that can go through courts for
a very long time before situations have
resolved often still with ongoing abuse
and so it's the support that people
still need whilst going while still in
those sort of situations
but as it says there we offer one-to-one
um support it does say we're trained
hopefully
volunteers
and that's something we will again
rebuild
counselling
again we identified there's a big need
for counselling we use a combination of
trained counselors and trainee
counsellors to provide this service
to people who who need it again i i hate
to say we've got over a 12 month waiting
list
for people trying to access that service
and again unless you you want to
obviously try and give people that
support you look for other places but
again there's very few places where you
can get counselling at the moment or
certainly not without very long waiting
risks full cost or cost ours is a
pre-service
women's support group again we're
answering all right horizons although
that's been suspended um but it's again
a peer support group um please take
being signaled the time and day on that
one um but yeah again a recovery mutual
support for people
pattern changing
yeah this is a really important
educational course that we provide
um
again it says on there what it does
it promotes the right to live free from
violence and abuse um foster's
self-confidence self-esteem and
self-worth again we have
tried to adapt during covid all our
groups previously have been face to face
and of course kovid
was a great big challenge
since then we managed to um
we've been doing it virtually over zoom
so we have still been able to provide it
to
smaller groups of individuals and in
fact feedback's still being very
successful so going forward we are in
september going to go back to face to
face but also we are also going to do a
zoom pattern changing as well which will
be good also for those people who suffer
for example anxiety and don't like
actually going into group work
situations and also um accessibility for
those who may be isolated and can't get
to
the groups which is general yeah which
can't get to our groups i would say they
are generally advanced but that's unfair
because we do actually try and in normal
times do it to other places such as
south mountain wholesale so again trying
to
um give the opportunity to as many
people as we can to access the room
so the behavior change service that is
being delivered by state support service
it's um
one of the biggest
things that we're looking for obviously
is motivation to change um
they don't have to be accepting it you
know everything they do is wrong i think
we just need a glimmer of some
motivation that you know that we can
work with
um
[Music]
the group of men and women that we are
working with tend to be more high-risk
offenders they will have um a criminal
background um
of sorts you know some sort of huge some
not so so huge so
part of that means that um this role
sits in with probation
um and
the
integrated vendor management team so
that team is probation primarily in
police
children's services are part of that as
well
so um they meet regularly obviously to
talk about um to talk about the
individuals and how they're how they're
doing or what they're up to
whether you know whether their
their behavior is so risky you know and
all sorts of things and it's kind of
modular if you like historically
perpetrators were
seen in groups
so that's why we've gone
to a one-to-one sort of basis so that
now we can open up a little bit more
and refuge that we provide um we have
got a refuge in north devon eight rooms
25 bed spaces so as you can imagine it
can be very busy over there at times
again we've got a brilliant team who
work very hard over there um
it is communal living
so again that comes with its own
challenges at times um but there's
specialist children's workers um there's
women's support workers obviously the
manager um
therapeutic groups they do over there um
yeah
yeah really inspiring place to be
again you know it talks there about
obviously the trauma that people can
suffer and children especially you know
arriving suddenly taken away from their
homes um to a refuge confused tired um
different needs i mean again you know we
work very closely to help them try and
rebuild their lives
again places of safety we've got
individual homes around the county for
male and female victims and those with
complex needs fleeing domestic abuse
again for us it was has been very useful
during copic times one of the houses we
have been able to put people in um
to
whilst waiting for tests once we know
that they're clear and covered like this
is going back to you know when we're in
the midst of it um once
you know the tests have been come back
positive they've been moved into the
communal house because again you've got
the challenges of kobe within communal
setting
[Music]
and again wrap around support this
provided
so our young people so we have got an
independent list of finance
and she can support 14 to 18 year olds
they are young people that are in their
own relationships so this is not about
parent using a child
obviously with children's services
um
um
children or young people that are a bit
older maybe 19 20 months and up to 24
they're they're likely to be
a young person possibly with a learning
disability
um
a young older person so maybe they're
still at university or they're still in
learning they're still living at home
with their parents um or they all care
leavers
so but primarily their work is from 14
to 18 years and
a lot of their work is around
risk is around
safety and around healthy relationships
um
yeah
they do tend to work with them for much
longer than the older uh the older
victim from the better word
and they you know they tend to need a
lot more support um
[Music]
again it's a really really small team
and we've got one one worker um that's
not even full time um but they can work
with some of the children with some of
our families their primary uh referrals
will be from the
allocated to them
the non-abusive um
partner or ex-partner will have a
dedicated worker as well and the
and it's about it's about safety it's
about resilience it's about coping it's
about understanding um what's going on
in their lives
okay having groups of children and
families
um this was there was a group called
grow together which was actually devised
by our children's worker this grew out
of her working refuge um and it's now
gone into the community and i'm really
proud to we were part of the national
project
where the group was
where the program was actually run into
areas um one in norfolk and one in
sussex and we had really good feedback
from it so
that's been really exciting but what
growth together is is of course
um at this stage for mothers
um and it's for those who want to
understand more about the effects on the
family
um the aim is to strengthen the
relationship that already exists between
mother and child building on awareness
of themselves their children looking at
barriers to communication
and it's hoped
mums can recognize the changes that need
to take place for
an power change basically moving forward
um like i say really really important
group that's been but she's also
developed it into of course for mothers
and children a child
um so it's runs as a parallel group so
you have ones in one room children or
the child in the other group and then
they they do it's all through arts and
crafts and play that's how communication
and relationships are developed and then
they come together and with that one
it's actually called grow together side
by side and the aim is to increase
understanding of healthy relationships
enhance resilience learn healthy coping
strategies improve parent and child
relationships and learn effective
communication again with backwards for
example we've had struggles due to covid
and in fact that's um
that had to stop and it's just been done
on the one-to-one basis for the mother
and child
does the the person that needs support
have to come to you and how much can you
go to them i mean are you ever referred
by the police do you ever make the first
yeah we
we get referrals um
all anyone that's referred into us has
to have consented but a huge a huge part
of the most referrals we get from the
police right we do get a second order
themselves but the majority of our
they would have to have been asked can i
can i refer you on to yeah yeah okay or
they can self-require yeah yeah yeah
because we are voluntary
yeah
and you know the places of safety
are they actually are they just like
safe houses or are they actually with
families or
with you know with them their individual
houses themselves it's not with based
with another family member right so it's
it's just
for that person
and how long can how is there any limit
on how you've been today in the refuge
yeah so that's it's based on their leads
okay and one thing one thing about the
children's work
presumably there must be an element in
there as well of
trying to to break the cycle because
some of
you want to some of the children will be
modeling behavior on what they've seen
in the family so some of it must
you know some of the work done with them
must be to do with that i would imagine
is that right yeah
and it's more on healthy relationships
you know
children domestic abuse certainly
within our groups
is healthy
relations yeah
how do you go
seeing what you how do you cope seeing
what you see and you're the people who
work with you i mean do you have support
yes yes
clinical supervision yeah very good
supervision yeah um
i obviously don't i don't i don't deal
with the victims i'm the lucky one but
you know so obviously i'm there to
support my staff as well as much as i
can and make sure that they're okay but
yeah yeah i think
we've been doing it for a long time i
think we're relatively resilient as well
and i think it's also the support
through one another so again and i'll
keep going on about covert obviously
that's been a major impact on us you
know again not working in the same
office people working from home that has
had a major effect on you know
[Music]
thank you
you alluded to the
fact that mental health was normally the
biggest issue problem and uh you know i
have been one of those uh people who
suffer with a bit of mental health uh
back along and uh
it must be really frustrating because
you know we don't think we're ill we
think we're fine everybody else is wrong
and
you know it must be difficult trying to
get someone to consent to how
yeah you know
[Music]
do you have um you know training for
that
all the staff would have done some sort
of training about mental health um i'm
not sure if they get lots of people that
don't know i'd say it's more the other
way around people going i'm struggling i
need help like this and that and not
being able to access
news you know yeah so yeah it is more
people talking about yeah and doing more
that way yeah and you know
yeah our workers are very very good at
making people feel safe and secure
um and that you know
confidential within the realms of
compute confidential by law obviously
but um you know so they they do create a
very safe
same environment for somebody to be able
to share their information
and i think also it's better to say
there's been
good pathways being built with devon
partnership trust in the rural mental
health services
it is a fact isn't it often it's the
husband the male partner in relationship
that is suffering and domestic abuse i
think a lot of people think you know
it's it's demands and wise
only
is it your is it your experience
oh no it can't affect you
yeah
yeah i mean
the proportion of our work is with
females
i'd say over the years when did we
because i was in the ada
there was a whole story that i was born
with we've got two feed and you know
definitely take it over but i mean we
were north damn women's age prior to
that obviously when we started
supporting men
we couldn't use that that term
um because a would put then off clearly
but um women's aid very strongly still
back yeah weren't they it was only they
weren't women and we were like no you
don't want to do that so
yeah we weren't allowed a male worker
you know
yeah so so you know but over the years
and obviously we've both seen
[Music]
that was um very interesting and
certainly
personally quite illuminating um and
very
fussy to know
what is there and what's going on below
the surface often unseen and that brings
me to
question about awareness within the main
well not groups that target audience
that put it that way or
um
do you are you frustrated
that
there is
not always a level of awareness or
knowledge about what is out there or
what is being done or what is on offer
um is you are you satisfied with the
level of awareness or do you think
actually it would it could be better
i think it definitely could be more you
know we do obviously
do as much as we can and we're often
going out and talking to groups
you know but yeah there could be more
there are still people out there that
have no idea that there are services
that we offer
which is very very sad obviously so part
of our job is to get into
the iris project with the gp surgeries
you know offering that training
training the gps to be more curious and
ask more questions themselves with their
consultations with people you know um
that's a lot worse obviously
um but we're also
quite covert as well so it is difficult
because
um
you know
we i can't have staff out representing
in the public because
they could be seen with a victim and
somebody could see them and it you know
we're a small community aren't we
um so you know they we have to be sort
of there are elements to being quite
covert as well so with us
you know getting that balance right but
yeah anything advertising
just as a follow-up the
because we we are we are interested
obviously in the reality of what's going
on both
the the unpalatable facts as well as the
gloss side um
just describe
your capacity versus
the
need
are you
i mean presumably you're not able to
cope with everybody who needs your
services or you have a there is a
waiting or a referral list or whatever
which is probably getting ever longer um
your comment on that we don't have a
waiting list
um we can't have a waiting list with a
very high risk we have to respond
uh because you know the need is there
then the wrist is high
um
i've got um
four five
so it doesn't matter how many they've
got they have to respond so it would be
more our medium risk clients that um may
have to wait a bit longer but actually
we do tend to generally always get on
target contacting or attempting contact
with with referrals within five working
days that's our that's our target
um obviously it's within 48 hours for
high risk
so we do tend to to keep that no don't
we don't have waiting lists um
so i don't know how we manage it but we
do
do you have a feeling that demand is
increasing yeah oh yes and therefore
eventually
that is going to impact unless your
capacity increases eventually you're
going to start to tip over a bit and
that's why you know
we're always looking for new projects
and funding streams and you know
as a result of the success of the mental
health complex needs but in the north
which has
been delivered by ndaa we're on our role
in that out into our dne which will
create two new workers i know it's not
going to affect the north but you know
that's that's kind of how things expand
so we are we have expanded a lot over
the years
um due to need but i guess
we've always i think it's a very
interesting thing actually this whole
point because you've got the higher
medium risk which splits primarily deal
with and have to deal with it's then the
moving on which then comes to our
service we have nowhere to move anyone
on to
so when i talk about our standard risk
and specialized services we have all we
get is people coming in
and it's very hard you know obviously we
work with
as many people as we can
the frustration is there is only a very
small team i'm literally talking handful
of workers
um but you know
the long-term effects of domestic abuse
are massive you know affecting you know
again with that mental health effects on
children effects on you know so many
aspects of people's lives and often
domestic abuse is seen as
a you know the primary course of that
so like i say people come to us for the
recovery we do not have anywhere to move
people on to our counseling list is over
12 months um our patent-changing lists
we have um about
i hate to say it you know we do have
about 150 people on our waiting list for
pattern changing we provide what
one-to-one services we can
and yes capacity is a big issue
again
the services for the children there are
so few services out there especially for
children affected by domestic abuse um
you know we provide one of the only
services
basically don't we yeah
so yes there's a big need a big demand
and there's only so much we can do
and you know it's really difficult to
um you know find ourselves in that
situation but we do best that we can and
you know we certainly do work with a lot
of
domestic is deprivation link
i think
specific studies but i know
poverty
poverty
certainly yeah
because it was that rural um yeah that
rural uh
report that came out a couple years ago
wasn't there on it
well i know the archers did a very good
storyline yeah two years ago
i know there was four or five families
really badly affected by that story yeah
that was coercive violence not
necessarily
absolutely
which is a different thing but you know
this center in many respects i just
wondered if you had
any any uh reaction to
that storyline that went into rural
areas i asked about deprivation possibly
there is but you know i look around at
some of the relationships
[Music]
which is quite interesting and there's
different issues that affect you know
people in different areas in terms of
you know whether it be on awareness
whether it be on being able to access
that support
um
in the middle of a small family or
something um you know you might have
difficulties with track now sorry i'm
being very stereotypical here but you
know transport issues trying to get
wi-fi you know what that's like that's
all right yeah
exactly yeah
exactly
and again you know this is it when
you've got big decisions being made on
national level you start thinking one
minute we don't live in a nice city
where you can get from a to b that
easily you know when they were looking
at closing our pool you know
back some time ago hang on a minute if
you're out the other side of your
smoking and you're expecting people to
get back to there you know
you know so these
and i just see children being dragged
between battle between two parents
i have quite strong feelings but i'm not
going to go into it right but we do have
challenges with the systems that we work
with
um
i think that's fair to say we do have
very big challenges and again we've
always come from a point of advocating
you know and trying to work with other
agencies
and
there are certainly ones which can be
quite challenging to access
um and
okay the final question for me um we are
approached and every four years we've
got to go to the electric if we want to
get elected again
and i've always enjoyed canvassing
because you get to see lots of places
i'm an independent the conservatives
always like being recorded just to stop
me from their campaign so i had a lot of
good free media conservatives for you to
charge them all right
but equally you google places sometimes
well be sometimes support but you get a
feeling of
concern
how should a counselor deal with that
appropriately could you give us some
guidance so we can fit in and guide
people in those situations i
i mean
we're meant to be
getting disability on bar services for
ourselves just to protect anybody from
when we're going into houses but you
also get a feeling sometimes
you know um
that's going on um
[Music]
anxious you seem a bit low today or i
don't know it's those kind of questions
that could lead somewhere um
but you know i guess you could ask
directly but i guess that you might
offend people then
yeah you know and you know it's just uh
i think it's more like those kind of
questions yeah
that's the kind of things we're saying
to the gps you know and
um questions about that sort of thing
really
i mean we had a classic powder in the
sun and that's a um
20 years later so we'll be known here
but um an agricultural situation where
the sun
[Music]
didn't behave correctly and the father
took pitchfork to him
um and the lorry came to deliver some
materials to the farmyard and farmworker
back to laurie and the large driver saw
what was happening and said look you
better do something there or it happens
every day they say
violence has been the norm for
for a lifetime
for something for a situation like that
[Music]
and so okay one one final follow-up for
me
following our our need and our thirst to
go away from here with a
a picture of the reality
um
excellent presentation you let us throw
all the relevant
parts and offerings that you have
i now have to say to you
what
element
doesn't work or
are you dissatisfied with or do you
think do you feel that you don't deliver
to the level that you would want to
um
you know well we're not getting names in
a report but there's you know nothing is
perfect
and i'd just be interested to know which
part you feel feel his most vulnerable
law is is not actually
working as well as it should do could do
or community needs it
i think for me um from the recovery from
our point of view recovery services is
down to capacity and resources i think
that is fundamentally where we have got
we struggle you know but we're a charity
we do we always have struggled in that
so
we're very lucky that we've got a very
creative organization you know which
does embrace the challenges and does try
um and overcome them um we've got very
creative ceo as well you know we've been
very well led um but
you know it does come down effectively
to some capacity from our side
council laws did you raise your hand i'm
sorry today yes thank you i'm sorry i
arrived late i'm not part of this
committee so thank you for letting me
speak
um i really want to say
keep up the good work keep fighting the
fight because
mental health is
terribly important
and
it leads to depression if you don't
if it's not addressed
i myself had a
quite a major breakdown
and it wasn't addressed well i was told
to snap out of it which was
what used to be said by doctors
and it led to a long-term thing
and i had to learn to get away from
myself etc etc
went on for several years when i
couldn't even leave my home village
uh and luckily i've come through and
i've come out the other side made me
more determined to be in a place like
this but it really is important the work
you do there was nowhere in those days
this is 40 years ago where you could
return other than your doctor
and just keep up the good work
[Music]
you know we're very keen to know what's
in our local community to work in
partnership and utilize for example
we've um refuge have been working with i
think it's chill or wave or one of the
surfing groups so again it's also
thinking outside of the box seeing what
you know what other
things what other activities we can link
in with in the community because there
are quite a few um different pockets but
thank you so much for saying that
count to the leather and then i think
i'll wrap up when you're yeah thank you
um thanks for the presentation
and the partnership is established i
think 2018
right and splits won the
tender from norway from denver county
council yeah
2014.
oh um we've got
we've we've had it renewed since the
original uh win which was 2014.
we've got about another five years four
five years ago on the contract
it's a one-on-one contract so we have to
achieve the outcome set by the devon
county council yeah
how do you measure success
and
listening to the presentation
the work of the partnerships
and domestic and sexual violence in the
whole a dreadful thing
a terrible thing and what really sticks
in micro is the fact that it's it's the
mother and children are taking out that
situation
and having to leave the family home
while the abuser sits there usually
male usually
sits there
back in the family and the children are
uprooted take note of their usual
everything in all their friends nearby
and all the rest of it and into a refuge
and invest well in the world
it's not very ideal isn't it
no it's it's not uncomfortable
well no i would we would completely
agree with you yeah
it's not right
we never see you hear about any of these
abuses
does it reach the papers of an abuser
being prosecuted
and sanctions against that people i'll
never read about that well the media and
that's the secret to these family courts
too which to be honest
in many respects for me
family courts have been
done a lot of disservice i think yeah to
mothers and children in some of the
instances
on family court so if anybody you know
that was really
what we're dealing with but i would
agree with you yeah my colleague
councilman mentioned waiting this and
you said you've got to deal
yes as a member you didn't mention in
the presentation 12th month wasted that
was for your services that's the
counselling
which is too late
you know nobody can wait for 12 months
when they need that
back to the capacity
and how do you measure success that
you've also
and obviously um
you know
we ask our clients at the end of their
support having friends and services so
there's a series of questions that we
will ask i do report that regulating the
county council yeah yeah up to their
health and well-being
no this is the domestic abuse
commissioners yeah committed yeah they
are under health and wellbeing yeah
they're commissioners yeah
my final question is to both of you um
what do you think that this council
could do to help you is there anything
that comes to mind
you know is there something we should be
considering
[Music]
grant of money each to distribute
um and i think i will propose to my
fellow councillors that if we could
contribute i think it's two and a half
thousand to like that and changing is it
yeah it is yeah well this is gone
some of us may wish to distribute more
um
and i think we'd like it to be running
yeah
that might help with the 150 or so that
you've got weight in
and i'm not sure council pension you may
have to advise me how would we look
forward for
these guys to be considered in the next
budget which will be set in november you
can make a recommendation you can post a
recommendation of the present
stacey reminds you better than me
actually but
um you can have a recommendation from
this committee to go to cnr
either you put 100 from each of our
budget didn't i was thinking of the
budget for 2022.
next year's budget
yeah
well i mean we haven't set an extra
budget yet anyway so we've got the do
lectures budget but you any any of us
can make a recommendation here you can
vote on that recommendation that we look
forward to i think the cnr will be the
correct procedure to make a decision on
that
we're going to start a budget setting
shortly so we'll have a special
full capital to do that so generally
speaking and with this sort of stuff it
would go to cnr but because we have
already said set this year's budget it
would be next year's budget so i'm
thinking of
contributing this year from our own
personal pots and looking at core
funding for 22 20. well you can make the
duel recommendation if you service for
20 22 23 budget
if you wanted to
and do i mean
[Music]
we do apply for a grant to go to ndada
next year and what that level might be
we would need some help with what kind
of
figure would we would be helping us know
he's making
a small sum available that is now the
use of ornament
and what kind of 2 500 council 11
2500 will run a pattern-changing course
which is 10 weeks
12 weeks and heather has explained that
she's got around 150 people waiting for
that course
so my idea is of paying for a course in
this financial year out of our own
budgets
and then looking at core funding in 22
23.
financially is
right will you send something wrong i
will either
really if that helps as well i can send
you some of the outcomes to sort of show
them
something
[Music]
i'm aware you already hate your next
meeting can i just say thank you so much
for having us
[Music]
oh did you sorry council ever hasn't
posted his budget yep does he have a
second day
[Music]
so you know it's great for our clients
as well as part of their recovery so it
is so
important
we've both co-delivered yeah it's an
amazing cause yeah
if we could help just reduce one of
those yeah
[Music]
thank you very much thank you thanks for
having me
[Music]
and all those in favor of that
i think
[Music]
[Music]
yeah okay thank you that's very
interesting
um presentation
so next we move on to partnership
evaluation
um
karen is kindly bored with us the forms
have we got them on screen can we get
one screen or is that just going to be
crazy
[Music]
and um
before each group come and presentation
presenter sorry um they will be
forwarded in a
it's not a questionnaire but what is
expected of them and then now that
heather and julie have left karen will
afford them perhaps tomorrow perhaps
next day
um
another form are responsible they will
give us feedback on
the
how they felt things went today what
they got out of it
um those forms are
fairly old
a couple of years
i think so yeah a couple of years old
and i think mr topham that's correct was
um reviewing and evaluating those forms
to see if they were in date out of date
if we should answer them take stuff out
refresh them etc etc
um
i think what i'm looking for is
perhaps a couple of you a small group to
have a look at these forms
and perhaps give them a bit of a refresh
counseling yes
certainly the the form that goes out um
prior to somebody coming and giving a
presentation we identified quite
recently the need for that to be
updated and to be
to spell out quite clearly
what we wanted we didn't just want gloss
we we actually
need to get under the surface and see
reality uh and we we identified at the
time that that form was a good way of
trying to communicate that message
i'm happy to be involved in
any review that you want yeah okay any
other volunteers
that's kind of injured chair this forum
i printed off the
evaluation partner evaluation for
correct questions in there and they're
in there
it will be up for your organization to
have more or better contact with the
council i remind this new chief so
there's a box
for whoever to write in there but i mean
the questions
that's the evaluation form
is
those pre-schooling meetings as well as
following up after the weekend that took
place to make sure
that uh there was a follow-up was the
intention i felt from liquidity
okay and we're happy to do that by email
with the group that comes in
and if councillor newton is happy to
look at the
pre-meeting very happy too that's what
people would want is anybody happy to
look at the after meeting
post me
i will
i'll be meeting
and i think that we can bring the
revised editions to the next meeting in
october are you happy with that
yeah yeah
yeah
sure can i just um raise uh ask that we
write about it
i do understand there's no residuals
he has been thanked
he has been thankful yeah there was
emails like effective as well even
though i didn't know i didn't see that
yeah
[Music]
just all the all the actual meetings
rather than just doing it it should be
really good he has been a good service
and i suppose that we do actually right
from this community to thank him for the
service he's done i i do call for a
secondary because he has been a really
good servant to this community
[Music]
in the post would be quite nice as well
okay
anything else on the evaluation process
um
so we've kind of covered mental health
um through here um next month we've got
environment biosphere drainage and
stewart joint meeting with north devon
council which we're actually waiting for
confirmation is that right damn it
on foreign sewerage
uh well we've got a joint meeting with
north devon council yeah that that was
going to be yeah community safety
partnership oh okay so it's one of the
other
the theme through that one that was
coming through was the environment okay
um so there was a link there between the
biosphere
and
southwest water um
the sewage works um the environment
agency so we had a theme coming through
um that looked at the the quality of our
environment and that was i think the
drive where the community was coming
from um so we haven't identified anyone
holy that we'd like to invite you phil
who was doing the driving on that
because it was north from this joint
says joint on here so was that house or
was the north definitely i think we
decided it would be one of the number
it's either going to be the community
safety partnership joint meeting once we
get confirmation correctly if i'm wrong
danny which will then bump the
environment into cycle sticks
and we haven't had confirmation yet and
we're kind of like that's getting
the suggestion or the proposal of an
environment beating that
which is shown as being joint also
i i didn't know where
whether that was
us making the running on it or whether
north devon were making the running on
it um
i don't think anybody's making the
running is my gut feeling
[Music]
partnership and if we're going to do a
joint meeting then if not perhaps we can
um contact biosphere
get them in
or who do you want
did we talk about having two joint
meetings
i thought
well i talked about health that the last
um ford plan which wasn't adopted uh um
at the platform because i think that you
know we have shared our debt in
healthcare right okay maybe that's and
there is the north american healthcare
trust agent next wednesday as well by
the way
um that we ought to be watching if
you're on this committee but um
we ought to have something on help with
north devon and we have done enjoyment
with no endeavour in the past
but it is it's to me
very noisy that there's nothing on
health
um
[Music]
we can add that to the forward plan and
perhaps march was actually late
i think it's really interesting that the
north dakota healthcare trust and the
world that in exeter
are now
on multiplating boards and i think we
have to be asking questions
about the value and quality of the
services that will be
looking to ourselves i mean in the past
there's been a weird discussion about
what will be left in north bevin and
maternity and
accident emergency and there was even a
discussion at one point that a e would
close down and and the board is now
multimating and it's going to be really
interesting on next week to see how
they're going to interpret that
i think we should be asking and holding
to account what services
are local to our own area we are having
a recent population here i don't know
out of the population perhaps we can put
that into january then that'll give them
time to have their board meeting now
september and then it will give them a
quarter to sort themselves out and
decide what they're doing
well i i'm happy wherever you want to
put that in basically i mean but i would
like to see something
picking up on what will be the proposed
changes and again you know the same all
the health professionals are doing to
north dakota and torridge and i think
there's a real strength in voice because
of the provider um
also linked to mission groups as well
um we should be asking questions of the
commission group and the providers which
is work that healthcare trusts them
effectively of how this amalgamation
will affect services across our area and
perhaps that should be a joint meeting
as well and between us and north london
i should bring in gps lack of gp
services as well
well let's try and arrange a group of
that one before we plan for january okay
and then we'll work together and see who
we can get into
okay
yeah i think one will be good
because it does cover both of our
districts
that keeps us going if we're wanting to
slightly
poke with a sharp stick
we are without doubt
stronger if it's the two councils
together without belt i would only like
to have that meeting if it was joined
between the two districts i think the
one on the sewage and drainage
came up originally because
i think we were talking about having the
environment agency
because the government is supposedly
going to be camping down raw series
going out into the sea and into the
rivers
and we felt that yeah we should be
looking at that because we do have
problems in our area along our clubs
with raw sewage still at times going
into the
into the rivers and sea
should be involved it should be a joint
because it affects them as much as
that's i think where that originally
came from
now at the moment um fox mills is um
meant to be having all
um piped up and treated um sewerage but
uh waiting for a water uh ford to uh say
whether they're going to do it or not so
is that the waterboard or the
environment though the environmental
agency has said it's going to be done
with cleaner waters that there is raw
sewage going out over the falls
uh from property standard bugs bills and
and now at the moment but
i've got three houses they want to sell
but they can't sell because they can't
get because of the uh stand still so
we've got um torridge's um uh trying to
get
the water authority to
make a decision so that they can get on
with it but i mean because
consultation's already done everything
but you know for us and my ward uh
there's people in limbo do you have a
contact with the environment agency that
you've been speaking to
do you have a contact at the environment
agency that you've been speaking to no i
don't but i mean uh i mean
we we are we're we've been dealing with
it because uh we've had to do it on our
level for uh to get some funding but
torrance is kind of uh pushing a bit of
lead and leading us through so we've had
uh um i forget what the challenge is
called have you got contact yeah um
because i haven't confirmed
a first-time service
we've assisted parish councils to put in
with southwest water and i will agree
that the time skills are very
frustrating
by that authority um
there's two sides in terms of the
sewage discharges to the sea
um there's the
the enforcement side is the environment
agency however the
the systems primarily are southwest
water systems so it seems like there's
there's two sort of areas potentially
for southwest water
to uh to speak to the
to the committee on i'm not sure really
what the environment
[Music]
of people is discharging um into the sea
or
can deal with the um
uh rest the uh the sewage system
application in boxing that would be down
to southwest water
the environment agency to brief us on
the
current
state of our coastline
because they as james said they're
responsible for monitoring and
reinforcement so they they should know
where
the
pollution is
and
we also invite southwest water to come
and tell us what they're doing about it
it's actually an area of
probably one of the
areas of greater public interest that
we've looked at in recent times well
it's this strong storm water overflowing
businesses particularly in new york
has come from the laws of north dakota i
mean there's a new estate well all the
new estates down there all the surface
water drainage either goes to
attenuation bonds and into well there's
no streams there above them on the
currents so when there's any heavy rain
in it and it's not really heavy rainfall
now it's less and less what we would
call exceptionally heavy rainfall that
the
surface water drainage can't take it
with all the new properties having
separate surface water drainage you've
only got look at the
times in the land overflow to go onto
the barrels
yes i was highly involved back in the
1990s through this principle
with southwest water
and you have a problem here
that cannot be sold
we have to understand
that
sewage and
[Music]
clean fresh water rain water are mixed
in our system here as they are
throughout
they're not treated separately
so when you get a huge amount of rain
the systems naturally have to overflow
so people say well why can't you store
it and i was explaining to me if you
wish to store
after a storm
all of north dam remember here we're
catering for
uh south south barnstable remington
insta wesley biddeford north africa and
west virgo
they said we would need a place
a attachment upon the size of melbourne
reservoir
if nothing was to be leaked from the
system
the system is working well
there's plenty of capacity for all the
new houses we're told
but i'm very sorry to say when you get
heavy rain
that the plants can't cater for it
cannot process that speed and it will
spill and it'll continue to spill from
my lifetime whether we like it or not
thank you
thank you council laws okay so i think
what we'll do is wait to see if janet
gets a response from north devon on the
community safety partnership
if that doesn't happen in cycle four
karen you and i can get together and get
someone in from the ea in southwest
water jan's got some contacts we'll sort
that
um
so that's kind of next month sorted one
of those will obviously
be bumped into a further cycle
six or seven depending on when we can
get the um
ccg
and
um nhs
to do something with us so that kind of
fills up two cycles there
can i go back to the community safety
partnership again of course um
uh
i think it was october
19 we had the last meeting with the
community partnership and there was a
bit of a contentious meeting because um
inspector toby davis
[Music]
um and i think he was there to inform us
and not to take any recommendations
there was quite a bit of con conflict i
think went on within the meeting and i
just wonder if we could scope the
meeting a bit before we have that
meeting so that we are aware of what we
are wanting from each other from that
meeting because i think that it's a duty
there is a legal duty i think it's in
the constitution we have to have this
meeting every year which i think we
missed last year but i don't want to get
in the difficulty that we have one year
like a pre-zoom call or something
well that's right i don't i i just
wonder whether you want to have a
scoping meeting prior just to make sure
you you're asking the questions you want
to ask
okay anything else on the forward plan
i think we're
okay so that brings me to
exclusion of the public we don't have
any
and i think that's the end of the
meeting so thank you to those on youtube
for watching us i hope you enjoyed that
and thank you all for taking your time
to come today much appreciated and of
course the ladies that presented to us
today